hey guys it's justine welcome to the
first and only unboxing of the new
samsung galaxy s10 plus that you will
see here on youtube
no one has done one yet just kidding
i'm sure at this point you guys have
already seen people unbox these but i'm
pretty excited because i just got mine
in i ended up buying the one terabyte
white ceramic version and this thing has
looked so beautiful like the photos that
i saw online some of the videos that
i've seen
this is kind of weird because like this
is a brand new phone new box it's like
sort of
seems like they're missing some sort of
seal here
there's only one little safety seal here
but like the box is half opening
on its own like this is brand new like i
don't know also in today's video we're
going to be unboxing the new galaxy buds
let's open it seems like everything's in
order
what have we got up here something is up
here we've got
some of our paperwork in here
this device includes a pre-installed
screen protector if you remove it and
want to use a different screen protector
make sure it allows for the use of all
touchscreen okay blah blah blah
ultrasonic fingerprint sensor so
excited to test that out let's get you
out of this box little guy
wow this looks
so good
man i don't even want to put a case on
it get in here look at this
get into it
the white ceramic i am slightly freaking
out
how good it looks i am really glad that
this does come with a screen protector
already installed and i've loved that
oneplus has been doing that for quite a
while
this looks so good look at the three
cameras
i thought that i was really into the
lilac lavender color from last year of
the
s9 but it really got old
really quickly because it didn't really
fit any other color scheme that i have
pretty much all of my color schemes
white black and rose gold and the purple
even though purple is one of my favorite
colors just really didn't fit
and i got really sick of it also inside
the box we've got our
usb charging brick the usual
usbc converter and our
akg headphones another usbc cable
there's just something about this
braided cable that i just love it
this i thought this was a worm super
disturbing
these are the extra little sizes for
your earbuds
starting up my gosh i can't i seriously
can't get a look at this like it just
really is
it's beautiful like it looks really good
okay let me help you get set up more
easily by guiding you through the steps
you're right let's look at the terms and
conditions
once you read and agree to yep i agree
take my body you can restore the
settings and contents from your old
wi-fi would be quite handy here so this
is where
i guess it's time to say bye to my pixel
for the time being this is the phone
that i have gone back to
all of last year like i always have a
secondary android device
so the s9 and the pixel 3 were basically
the two phones that i
alternated between the last bit of last
year
so this is this is where we say goodbye
for the time being my friend until the
pixel 4 comes out this also has 12 gigs
of ram
in the terms and conditions which is
pretty incredible okay i agree to
everything so what's different about
the s10 plus is it does have two cameras
but one of these cameras
is really only used for depth sensing so
when you're taking those portrait mode
style photos with the blurred
backgrounds
using this depth sensing camera it's
able to kind of pull you
away from the background so it's kind of
using ai in a sense to sort of determine
where you are
where the background is and what should
be in focus i cannot wait to try this
camera out
but right now we've got to go through
the setup process setting up new phones
is
so exhilarating again my fingerprint oh
my gosh okay it's happening it's
happening it's happening it's happening
let's set this up are you guys ready are
you ready for this
have you seen this before this is the
new ultrasonic
fingerprint sensor so i have to press a
little harder okay
how hard you want to push i feel like
i'm pushing
pretty sick pretty hard actually
i mean that's a lot harder than i was
thinking i'd have to push maybe that's
just for the setup i have to push that
hard
okay if i have to push this hard on my
phone every single time i'm doing this
like i feel like i'm gonna crack it i
don't even know what i'm clicking i'm
just agreeing to everything which is
probably a bad
bad idea all right i think one of the
things that a lot of people had been
mentioning in a bunch of their reviews
and online is how great they did with
the
backgrounds and trying to hide the notch
it's not a notch anymore it's the whole
punch cut out but you know what i mean
one of the other things that i've really
been enjoying is i was following through
these threads marquez tweeted
all of these backgrounds that people
were making with like binoculars
and like wall-e and all sorts of
different like robots and kind of
integrating that wallpaper into
the hole punch cutout i was so amused i
was losing my mind i'll put a link to
that thread on twitter
in this description of this video
because it was so amusing that i just
was
really enjoying myself looking at those
so here's going to be the first time
that i'm going to test out
the fingerprint sensor this again is
ultrasonic so it's using sound waves
instead of light like the oneplus phone
does i hope that you guys are ready
because
okay that wasn't bad i think maybe just
the setup was making me press really
hard
because i'm pressing at a normal rate at
this point and it's totally fine so i
think
the setup was just making you press
harder so that you can get a really good
fingerprint read
let's test out the
camera where's our camera at i guess
i'll just take a picture
the ultra oh my god
you guys have to see this picture you
have to see this picture
i'm losing my freaking mind the ultra
wide this picture
my arm i look like stretch freaking
armstrong
there is no doubt about it you cannot
deny that this is absurd
this is this is crazy wow i love it so
much
okay so this is normal this is the 2x
zoom
this is ultra wide and don't mind this
office setup honestly
i swear one of these days i'm gonna get
my office life together but for now
this is what we've got so the live focus
oh
wow we what do we have there's different
effects
okay that's one effect this background's
pretty boring to say probably can't even
tell
a nice little vignette it's really hard
to tell the different backgrounds
because this background is so boring and
white i am going to be filming a video
here
it's a day with the s10 plus so look for
that very very shortly i'll be filming
that tomorrow since the unboxing is
officially complete
so if you guys can tell can you tell
there's also two options for a selfie
camera so this one's
a little wide angle with like the two
people and with the one person it's kind
of
cropped in here's wide angle it's
definitely not as wide angle as the
pixel wide angle pixel camera wasn't the
best
okay so now let's try a live focus
oh let's see okay let's find some
background the background
this is not a good place to be demoing
this
the beauty filter oh my gosh okay
make me beautiful samsung beauty filter
is on
so i'm gonna take a picture of myself
normally
now we're going to turn on all of the
beauty effects so i'm gonna turn skin
tone all the way up
lips oh my goodness i look like an anime
character
well one of my eyes seems to look
bigger than the other one in this
picture anyway can we just
take a moment to appreciate beauty
filter
is absolutely terrifying
[Music]
let's do an ar emoji which are
by far the most terrifying things
oh my god i'm so scared what's it gonna
look like what's it gonna look like
oh my i mean i'm wearing shorts
the last time that i wore shorts was
probably 10 or 11 years ago when i was
on the price is right those two things
not connected for some reason it was i
was wearing shorts i don't i do not like
wearing shorts at all
did i ever mention that i won the prices
right showcase showdown i look like i
have
hair coming out of my nostrils it's like
i haven't seen the light of day this is
i'm
absolutely disgusted with myself i for
the longest time thought my eyes were
green but my mom told me that
they were blue i was like
[Music]
gonna help you i need to put some pants
on that's like an outfit that i'd wear
hello so this is me this is my look this
is my shirt
i think i'm looking good you guys think
do you like my hair do you like my eyes
do you like my lips do you like my face
do you like my teeth
this is something that you will be
seeing in your nightmares tonight
i'll see you when you close your eyes
little ones
guys that's the unboxing of the new s10
plus i'm super excited to try this out
and spend a lovely day with it tomorrow
filming with it
but before we go guys we gotta open up
these galaxy buds
so let's open these up it's gonna be
hard for me to like anything
more than i like my air pods because i
love them
when i first got the air pods they
didn't really fit in my ears but for the
past couple of years my ears have sort
of conformed to the air pods
i don't know if i'm having a mutation of
some sort
but i am here for it and i love it but i
am very interested in trying these
let's see
look at you guys you look like little
they look like something i would eat
they have a nice smell to them they have
a very fresh smell here's the little
charging case
there's the little connectors there that
will charge them
and to connect these i should just be
able to open them up at least that's
what i saw on the demo
but yes here we go let's hit connect
um yeah i would love to yes please do
whatever you want
do it what do you take take my firstborn
please take it
oh this is a bit of a surprise
i actually really i like the feel
oh this is okay all right
i like that this has an integrated app
with it so this is kind of cool they've
got a little equalizer here so you can
adjust if you want dynamic you want soft
face boost clear treble boost i said
there's a new version of software for my
earbuds that are ready to download so
honestly super surprised these are
extremely comfortable and i'm having
no problems with them staying in what's
great is i can actually use these with
my iphone as well because they are
bluetooth so i would just have to sync
them and pair them to my phone
just like you would be able to sync or
pair your airpods to
your samsung devices or any other device
that has bluetooth connection
so far my review of the buds is
i really really like them i like them a
lot
i'm sad that you're empty that brings me
to the end of this video
so i want to thank you guys for watching
and i am looking forward
updating weather information oh my gosh
check back here very shortly for
my spending a day with the s10 plus i'll
be shooting that tomorrow
and kind of just going through and
testing everything out and just
sort of seeing what it's like to spend
the entire day with this which is
really super basic idea for video
so if there's anything you'd like me to
test out or try with this
leave those in the comments below and
now i'm gonna go and just
update this thing and get all my apps in
order so that i will be ready for all of
the fun tomorrow
so thanks for watching i'll see you
[Music]
later
you